we're into the vep stakes baby there are
still two maybe more two
even somewhat
registering additional Republican
candidates in the primary Beyond Donald
Trump that's Nikki Haley and Ronda santz
I think ASA Hutchins is still in it I
think there's another guy named Binkley
in it but you know they're they're not
really showing up anywhere the STIs and
Haley are barely registering for all
intents and purposes the primary is over
so now we're moving on to who is Trump
going to pick for his running mate
Donald Trump Jr has some thoughts could
you see your father running with Ron de
santis I asked him that question over
the summer and he didn't rule it out
could you see R how do you it's hard you
know people do that like you know I I
would do whatever I could to make sure
it wasn't Nikki Haley but uh you know
but like aronda santz could I see you're
never going to rule out someone that is
you know a leading Contender it doesn't
mean that's who you go with I could see
other people that would be great I'd
love to see you know a JD Vance I'd love
to see a Tucker car said I'd love to see
you know people who are just principally
uh you know in alignment as well as like
aggressive you actually need a fighter
the Republicans in Washington DC are
weak you can have the house the Senate
and they'll still roll over it doesn't
matter is your dad serious about Tucker
Carlson are those rumors serious I would
you listen that's clearly would be on
the table right I mean they're they're
they're very friendly I think they agree
on virtually all of these things they
certainly agree on stopping the
NeverEnding Wars uh and so you know I
would love to see that happen and you
know that that would certainly be a
contender I love Tucker Tucker would be
a cool Choice I'm fine with it I don't
think it's going to happen though the
reason I don't think it's going to
happen is I see no evidence that Trump
would pick a huge personality who in any
way could even somewhat compete with
Trump's huge dominant personality I
don't see any evidence of that at any
point in his 40 plus year public life
certainly not from the last pick the
last pick he made was to balance him out
a quieter guy from the Midwest who's on
board he's going to be supportive but
he's not going to really challenge Trump
or overshadow him he's not going to have
had public disagreements with Trump very
often as Tucker has so you know love
Tucker very conservative guy that'd be
terrific but I don't really see that
happening the next choice Elise
stefanic don't like that El Le stefanic
is is pretty liberal she's from New York
the reason that some are reporting that
she's being considered for VP is she's
been relatively loyal to Trump which is
good that's a good thing you you really
want someone who's going to be loyal she
wouldn't overshadow Trump in any way uh
but I still don't really see what she
brings to the
table she's a liberal
Republican who's totally identified with
Team Trump so even if Trump were trying
to do a Reagan Bush kind of thing thing
here you know you get the conservative
guy at the top of the ticket and the
more establishment liberal guy at the
bottom of the
ticket here the at least stepanic
doesn't really unite the party because
she's lumped in as a Trumper it's just
kind of like the the worst of all worlds
from an electoral
perspective the the more liberal
policies but but also the baggage that
goes along with supporting Trump if you
hang out with the country club
establishment set so and she's from New
York I mean it's not like Trump's going
to carry New York I don't really see it
happening DeSantis would be great I mean
love DeSantis absolutely great Governor
that can't happen because
constitutionally uh you can't have a guy
at the top and bottom of the ticket from
the same state it would it would uh not
work with the electoral college system
so you know just as a tech I'm not I
don't think Trump would pick to santis
anyway for the same reason I mentioned
above with Tucker I don't think he's
going to pick a a really tough
personality who's got a career of his
own who might but heads with him I just
don't see that happening but
uh certainly not someone who's
campaigned against him this has become
pretty nasty primary uh but there's also
just a technicality so I don't really
see that happening it's funny Don JR
says I really hope it's not Nikki you
know if Nikki is hoping for a Reagan
Bush kind of thing um that's the path
forward for her but if the Trump family
is against her and they think this has
gotten too personal and they can't trust
her then then she's out so that leaves a
really interesting choice there JD Vance
JD Vance is on the team he got elected
with a major endorsement from Donald
Trump he represents more the new right
the more populist more traditionally
conservative side of the party as
opposed to the alternately libertarian
side or the neoconservative side or the
globalist side you know JD does not
represent that he's also from Ohio and
they they would always say as goes Ohio
so goes the nation Ohio accurately has
predicted a lot of presidential
elections that predictive power failed
in 2020 but the Democrats rigged it in
2020 and changed all the rules hopefully
the rules will have been corrected a
little bit by the time we get to
November 2024 of the choices that were
just floated there JD is probably the
best one what do you think what do you
think let me know in the comments I'm
curious hello once again Mr nlls it is
slap my base coming at you with another
question so I have been tked to come up
with a funeral mass as I need to prepare
one for a relative who will be passing
on very soon and I wanted to ask you
what are some of your favorite funeral
hymns other than Amazing Grace which is
basically the staple I've already got a
couple in mind but I wanted to see what
you would think of as a good preference
and maybe I can add it to the catalog
once again thanks for everything great
question I tend to prefer even more
traditional than say Amazing Grace or
something like that so my first go-to
would be a Maria Schubert a Maria maybe
box a Maria maybe brahms's a Maria even
who knows um another a that would be
good would be a verum corpus would be
nice U but it sounds like you want
something a little bit more modern it's
considered old by a lot of modern people
but I consider a little bit more modern
like Amazing Grace so it depends if you
want something a little bit more modern
or even a little bit more Protestant How
Great Thou Art I really like really like
the Elvis version you know oh Lord my
God in Humble that's a good one
um but I I like the old sturdy
traditional hymns you know uh oh Jesus
we adore thee oh Jesus we adore thee who
in thy love divine I I I find that good
for a funeral
because a lot of modern funerals just
look back
with sadness on the loss of a person a
loved person and then they either openly
despair or they just fall into soft soap
about how well we know that person is in
heaven now even though we don't know
that for certain we we hope that that
person's in heaven we pray that that
person is in heaven but we don't know so
it it comes off as soft soap and Wishful
Thinking rather than a persuasive truth
I I prefer and I hope everyone Tak note
by the way you know I hope I live a good
long life but when my requim Mass is to
be said I want good solid hyms and I
want them preaching the gospel and
that's what I want I don't want
sentimentality about me I want good
sturdy gospel and good sturdy hymns
about Jesus and the reason I want that
is because that gives you real
hope if all of that's true if the
religion is true if Jesus is who he says
he is if God is real then we can
actually have hope that there is
something beyond death but if it's not
then we're all just going to be
despairing no matter how much we fool
ourselves a windy answer to a simple
question man what a great clip that was
now hold up ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael's YouTube channel we'll see
you next time